es el valle de sula una región al norte
de honduras una parte del corazón
industrial del país ahora bajo las aguas
aquí este jueves los equipos de rescate
buscan más supervivientes después de que
el lunes
yota tocará tierra en la vecina
nicaragua algunos han sido jornadas muy
largas
honduras y nicaragua son los países con
mayor cifra de fallecidos son dos
territorios en donde la cantidad de agua
sobre el suelo amenaza las labores de
rescate con deslizamientos de tierra
además la tragedia tiene un impacto
político por lo menos en nicaragua desde
la opositora unidad nacional denuncian
que en los últimos años el gobierno
fortaleció el presupuesto para defensa y
redujo el de la prevención de desastres
denunciamos a la dictadura de daniel
ortega y rosario murillo por su
negligencia y deliberada
irresponsabilidad ante esta emergencia
nacional la tragedia de yota también
enluta a colombia de la mano de su
archipiélago de san andrés y providencia
un territorio caribeño en donde parte de
la población denuncia abandono por parte
del gobierno
es una región que depende del turismo y
que ahora no solo sufre las
consecuencias de la pandemia sino
también del clima